today on the Matt Walsh show the new
jobless numbers are in the unemployment
numbers and they are absolutely
staggering we'll talk about those today
and five headlines including the
governor of California saying that the
current crisis were in should be used as
an opportunity to usher in a new
progressive era which is exactly what I
was talking about on the show yesterday
so as if to prove my point he came out
and said that we'll talk about it and
today we're gonna be canceling snitches
suddenly the America is full of snitches
specifically I'm talking about the many
Americans who are snitching on their
neighbors and business owners for not
socially distancing correctly so we're
gonna talk about all of that and much
more on the show today
but before we do I want to tell you
about our friends over at Rock Auto very
good friends of ours on the show great
sponsors of ours and you know if
something goes wrong with your car or
your vehicle right now especially right
now that that could be a difficulty in
fact we're we were going through that
right now with with actually both of our
vehicles went down at the same time and
you know you can't maybe you don't want
to go out to the store maybe you're not
able to especially if your car's not
working that could be another problem
and that's why rockauto.com is a
solution you just pull it out you've got
it in your pocket you go on your phone
rock out or calm it's so much easier
than walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
is your Odyssey and LX or an e X and
then you look stupid and you feel
emasculated if you can't answer it right
away and then they're just gonna order
the parts online anyway so forget about
that go to Rock Auto calm and that the
catalog there is unique it is remarkably
easy to navigate to navigate
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules to brake parts and tail
lamps motor oil everything you could
possibly want rockauto.com
always offers the lowest possible prices
that they can and you're always going to
have a great selection every time you go
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
okay
I know people complain to me that I harp
on the economic doom and gloom a little
bit
too much and maybe I do but you know I'm
hosting a show an essential show
podcasting is an essential service
during this pandemic in case you didn't
know but we in the media were essential
I'm of course everybody's job is
essential right everyone's job is
essential to them so that distinction
doesn't really make any sense to me
I'm anyway but I'm hosting as I happen
to be hosting a show during during a
period in history where our civilization
is willfully plunging itself into
economic ruination which as I have said
and many others have said is just
something that has never happened before
no no especially certainly in modern
history no country has chosen to do this
to itself so it's hard for me to see
that there could be very very many
topics more important than this to talk
about especially because I like to focus
on topics that I've always preferred to
focus on things that are going to affect
your life impact your life and your
family in in very direct ways those are
the things I think are most important to
discuss well here's here is something I
think the economic ruination of your
country is certainly something that will
affect you it will affect me it'll
affect everybody and especially when so
much of the rest of the media is all but
ignoring this the mass media the
mainstream media they're talking about
the virus of course but the economic
ruination of our society is not
something that they've deemed especially
newsworthy and they're giving us all
these projections these worst-case
scenario projections that keep changing
conspicuously about what the virus might
do and and and ok but what about some
projections on where we're headed
economically which brings us to today's
big news the kind of news again that is
impossible to ignore I think to talk
about anything else would be sort of
malpractice podcasting malpractice 6.6
million unemployment claims last week
6.6 million in one week in one week last
week was 3 million which was the
ever in recorded history so we have the
highest-ever record history last week
and then the next week this past week
was double the worst ever in history
this is what exponential growth looks
like we keep hearing about exponential
growth well here you go this is what it
looks like by the way that three million
figure was about four times worse than
the previous worst ever recorded it and
that was in 1982 and it was also more
than four times worse the worst recorded
during the Great Recession ten years ago
so this now now and then the six million
number I know there's a lot of math I
hope I'm doing all this right but the
six million number that is is about ten
times worse than the worst that had ever
been recorded previous to the economic
shutdown which brings us nice and
symmetrically to ten million unemployed
people officially in two weeks and I
emphasize officially because that
doesn't account for all the many
millions of people who don't qualify for
unemployment haven't applied or tried to
apply and weren't able to get through
because the websites are crashing all
over the country and the phone lines are
jammed so what's the actual number the
actual number is much higher than 10
million in two weeks it's which means
that the situation is much worse than it
looks and it looks catastrophic now you
probably don't need me to keep
rephrasing the numbers in different ways
but here's another way of looking at it
10 million jobs lost in 14 days averages
over 700,000 jobs a day lost which means
we're losing more jobs in a day than we
lost in a week
during the peak of the recession 10
years ago and these numbers despite what
you may hear do not represent simply
lost money it represents ruined lives it
represents suffering it represents
mothers and fathers who can't feed their
kids so at this point anyone who
responds to concerns over the economic
situation by saying you're putting money
over people anyone who
that way must either be a sub 65 IQ
[ __ ] or a liar because there's just no
way that a rational honest intelligent
person could fail to understand could
look at could look at the 10 million
unemployed people in 14 days 700,000 a
day and not understand why we're worried
about it I'm not saying that you have to
be dumb or lying to disagree with my
position that we should try to reopen
the economy I'm not saying that if you
support the shutdown's you're dumb or a
liar that's that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying you have to be dumb or lying
to argue that those of us who want to
reopen the economy while taking
precautions at the same time are a bunch
of greedy money grubbers you how could
any but you still hear this you're still
gonna hear this
10 million unemployed people you're
still gonna hear the argument
quote-unquote that if you are raising
economic concerns you're putting money
over people you don't care about
people's lives and most of the people
saying that they're not sub 65 IQ morons
some of them are most of them are just
liars they're trying to shut you down
they don't want this discussion and then
you really have to start questioning
their motives especially if we're
dealing with people in the media why are
they so desperate to prevent us from
having this discussion and talking about
where we're heading it headed
economically and projecting all this
projecting going on well projecting what
this will look like in two three four or
five months the hope of course is that
somehow everything will quickly and
quietly and easily just pop back into
place when all this is over like a
dislocated shoulder or something pop it
back into place and go about your day
economy opens up jobs come back
companies resurrect themselves from the
dead like a mass Easter miracle and in
the meantime the government just spends
a few trillion bucks here a few trillion
bucks there to keep the wheels churning
that's that's the hope that a lot of
people have and I hope that it happens
too I have no choice but to hope that of
course I hope that that's what's that
what what will happen and is it
impossible no of course it's not
impossible it is possible in the sense
that in sense that anything that is not
inherently illogical is therefore
possible
I mean it's it's possible that a
kangaroo could sprout wings and fly
across the the outback that's possible
technically probably not gonna happen
and with this the idea that the economy
is gonna easily quickly snap back into
place possible very unlikely though I
would think the greater possibility at
this point it's much higher likelihood
is that we are causing deep long-term
damage to our economy and our society
that will not be easily healed or
reversed that's probably what's going to
happen now yes when the shutdowns end
whenever that happened whenever that
should occur there are going to be
people who get their jobs back some are
furloughed and some of those will
actually get their job back there there
are others that lose the job will end up
getting hired somewhere else so nobody's
suggesting that if we end up with 40
million unemployed people by the end of
April which we very well could no one's
saying that those 40 million people are
never gonna get another job again but it
seems very likely that a large
percentage will be unemployed for quite
a while and even when people start
getting jobs again we're also looking at
a reordering a reshuffling of our
economy in our society in a very
fundamental way we're looking at a
corporate takeover which yes has has has
that's been in the process of happening
as we know in our economy for decades
but now this is that the final push that
sort of puts the nail in the coffin of a
lot of small businesses Walmart is still
hiring target is still hiring Amazon is
hiring while small businesses are
getting decimated completely decimated
which is which is a big coincidence
isn't it isn't it a coincidence that
places like these big these big retail
chains these big corporate chains in so
many cases they managed to get filed
under the essential column
while while small businesses are folding
up going under because they're not
essential it's interesting that the
companies with money and influence
happen to be essential while the small
businesses with very little money and
very little influence are not but don't
question that right
our bureaucratic overlords they have
decreed it and we you will just trust
them it doesn't inspire much hope or
confidence either when on the rare
occasion that you hear one of these
medical experts who are recommending
these steps when you hear them actually
address the economic and societal
implications acknowledge them at least
when they do invariably it really seems
that they don't appreciate or understand
the consequences of the steps that
they're recommending so for example dr.
Fauci pouchy was being interviewed this
morning
on The Today Show I believe and he's he
talks about the economic he does mention
the economic implications but look at
how he describes and categorizes them
listen the Surgeon General was on with
us just yesterday and said my advice is
that the 30-day guidelines to stay home
from the federal government amount to a
national stay at home order is that how
you see it - do you agree well yeah I
mean if you look at what's in those
30-day recommendations of the guidelines
that's essentially what it is I mean I
know it's difficult but we're having a
lot of suffering a lot of death this is
inconvenient from an economic and a
personal standpoint but we just have to
do it that is our major weapon against
this virus right now we don't have a
vaccine that's deployable this is the
only thing we have and we can get
through it if everybody really leans
forward and pushes inconvenient it's
inconvenient hey you're not allowed to
say 10 10 million jobs lost in two weeks
700,000 a day for two weeks
inconvenient 40 million jobs lost
probably by the end of the month
inconvenient
but on the other hand you're not allowed
to say that the coronavirus is just the
flu which which it isn't right but but
you can't say that yet the people coming
up with these policies can describe the
obliteration of our entire economy as a
mere inconvenience hey I know it's
inconvenient that you lost your
livelihood your income you have three
kids you can't feed house you can't pay
for bills you can't pay hey-ya small
business owner I know that you spent
your entire life working to this if you
put your whole life and everything into
this business it's everything you've
ever worked for and in the span of two
weeks you've watched to come crashing
down and taken away from you that's
inconvenient sorry about the
inconvenience no biggie
just think it's like a stubbed toe you
know a speed bump in the road no big
deal how do we accept that how is that
acceptable and as I said how much
confidence can it really inspiring us I
mean it's it's it's it's bad enough when
we feel like we can't trust the
projections the scientific projections
that doctors and scientists are giving
us but then when you realize that these
are people who have no grasp on the
economic implications and what they
actually mean by the way I also want to
mention us before we go to headlines
there is we look at this as as the
economy verse the health care system and
we have to shut down the economy to save
the health care system so the health
care system isn't overwhelmed right
that's the argument anyway and I think
that that the idea that we have to shut
down the entire economy to save the
health care system is wrong for many
reasons that I described ad nauseam and
there are there are other options but
there's also another another aspect of
this that actually what we're finding as
Davis over the federalists is a
demonstrated on Twitter this long tweet
thread I'll go through some of these but
what we're finding is that is that
actually shutting down the economy is
having a devastating impact on the
healthcare industry - so just reading
from Shawn Davis on Twitter says get
ready this is going to start happening
at hospitals and private medical
practices all over the country in the
name of flattening the curve we are
economically destroying healthcare
capacity and he links to an article
saying the Boston Medical Center has
furloughed 700 employees 10 percent of
the house hospitals workforce and then
there's a long thread of this sort of
thing happening in Ohio they've got 700
Mercy Health workers lose their jobs a
Kentucky hospital chain furloughs about
500 employees Connecticut Children's
Hospital furloughs 400 Prisma health
joins growing list of US hospitals to
furlough employees Williamson Medical
Center furloughing nearly 200 employees
that's in Tennessee and it goes on or
not all across the country we're finding
that that people in the health care
industry are losing their jobs now we
were told that there's gonna do the
house was overwhelmed all across the
country and so you're gonna the last
thing I be doing is laying people off
well no that's they're laying people off
and a lot of that is that is the gut is
the is the economic shutdown so this
this has implications beyond just people
losing their jobs as if you can really
put adjust in front of that it also has
implications for the healthcare industry
- let's move on to five headlines before
we do you know the all access live shows
what we've been telling you about
you really should if you're if you're a
deli wire member you should tune in to
one of these I think it's a lot of fun
and if you're not a daily why I remember
the member that become a daily while I
remember I did one yesterday and you're
so relaxed vibe you know just kind of a
Q&A type of thing but my three-year-old
son
barged his way into the all-access live
show and we was eight o'clock at night
on the East Coast anyway when we do
these he's supposed to be in bed he came
up and so he got he was he was a joined
me a cameo appearance for about three
minutes which by the way my other kids
yeah I have four kids and at least the
other two the youngest is a baby so
she's not really clued in but the other
my other the older kids when they found
out that their little brother got to
join me for you know for a show there
were jealous and so they want to be on a
show too so I think tomorrow actually at
the end of the show on a Friday I'm
gonna have my other kids in here and
we'll do a little Q&A with them I'll do
a little interview with my with my kids
off-camera I'm gonna keep them
off-camera to the sex I don't really
want one camera but we'll do a little
like I did with my son last night on the
show a little a little Q&A if you have
any questions for my kids you know
they're six years old they've got great
wisdom as many kids are these days my
kids are very woke so any questions you
might have and email them to me and I'll
maybe I'll ask them it could be a
political ideological philosophical
theological these are very wise
intelligent kids trust me anyway the
all-access live show yes I got
distracted they're all access live and
it's it was really originally gonna be
for our all-access members but now it's
for all daily wire members and so you
could tune in tonight at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific okay going to
five headlines number one governor Gavin
Newsom of California fielded a question
yesterday about weather look this crisis
is a quote opportunity to assure in a
new progressive era and his answer was
yes yes absolutely I'm wondering if you
see the potential as some others in the
party do for a new Progressive Era if
you want to call it that in national
politics and policy and whether there's
the opportunity for additionally
progressive steps such as the ones that
I listed on the national and state level
going forward you know because of this
crisis what's the opportunity to your
question for reimagining a more
Progressive Era as it relates to
capitalism and I'm a capitalist I'm a
small business owner I'm a job creator
well my customers are the job creators
I'm beneficiary of their support and
that helps build that demand that allows
me to hire more people and so as a
former business owner now governor I
have had that experience and I have that
appreciation of the importance of
consumer confidence consumer spending in
a vibrant middle class and so yes
forgive me for being long-winded
but absolutely we see this as an
opportunity to reshape the way we do
business and how we govern and that
shouldn't put shivers up the spines of
you know one party or the other I think
it's an opportunity of new for both
parties to come together and meet this
moment and really start to think more
systemically not situationally not just
about getting out of this moment but
more sustainably and systemically to
consider where we can go together this
historic moment if we meet it at a
national level in a state and
sub-national level so answer is yes this
is exactly what I was talking about on
the show yesterday you see that this is
not a conspiracy theory my concern is
that the response right now
from the government and the acceptance
of the response from the populace will
set a precedent for future liberal
regimes in the United States to exploit
and use to shove their ideological
vision agenda down our collective
throats and if you listen to them
they'll tell you that yes that is
exactly what we're going to do that's
exactly the plan as you just heard from
Gavin Newsom they're number two
Katherine sorts and Egger darter
daughter of Arnold took to Twitter last
night to urge the mayor of Los Angeles
to shut down the local farmers market as
she tweeted at the mayor saying the
farmers market in Brentwood still being
opened seems like a huge issue when it
comes to social gatherings now this
really annoys me because what's the goal
here to shut down every last small
business to ensure that nobody can earn
a living unless they work for a
corporate chain god forbid god forbid
somebody buy food from a place that is
not Walmart or Target god forbid they
patronize something that does
have a word Supercenter attached to it
there is no reason why you're at a
farmers market I don't care if it's
crowded a farmers market is at least
outside so why would it be more
dangerous to be outside at a farmers
market milling around even if there are
other people than it is to be inside
crammed in with a hundred other shoppers
at a Walmart or Target or someplace like
that number three the government over in
the UK is unveiling a GPS tracking app
that will warn you if sick people are
nearby it will track the sick people for
you and if there's one near you or
headed your way you can dive into the
bushes or something to get out of the
way now this is supposedly gonna be an
opt-in situation so if you're sick you
have to I guess sign up to be GPS
tracked by the government and it's hoped
or expected according to Sky News that
more than 50% of the population will
sign up for it can you imagine signing
up to be tracked by the government
explicitly signing up for it well I'm
sick better get my GPS coordinates to
the health department is that something
you could ever see yourself saying
here's an idea if you're sick stay home
avoid people that that way you don't
need to feel obligated to be tagged and
tracked like some kind of wild animal on
a nature preserve and I could also see
this backfiring in a big way it will
backfires already in terms of civil
liberties and privacy and everything but
well that's not really a backfire in
fact the whole point is to infringe on
those things so it doesn't it doesn't
backfire there it works but I can see
backfiring in somebody signs up for this
and they're sick and then they figure
well I can go out in public now because
everyone's gonna get a warning to get
out of my way so isn't it gonna
encourage people to leave the house when
otherwise they should just be staying in
and what if you have people like me who
might consider signing up and telling
the health department that I'm sick just
so that people will avoid me and get out
of the way that sounds kind of nice if
you're going somewhere you think it's
gonna be
did you know you just tell you you
register for the things that you say I'm
sick you walk into the building everyone
gets an alert on their phone danger
danger sick person and they all clear a
clear path like Moses parting the water
the Red Sea number for a dr. fauci was
asked when the social distancing will be
relaxed this was yesterday at the White
House press conference and he was asked
the question that's on everybody's mind
when are we gonna be done with this and
his answer was rather troubling
listen looking beyond when we're on the
other side of this curve are we looking
at living with some sort of social
distancing guidelines especially it
essentially until there's treatment or
vaccine for example people looking
forward to the summer talk about you
know going to baseball games going to
concerts we have political conventions
over the summer or things like that
possible or safe without a vaccine or
treatment place yeah I think if we get
to the part of the curve that dr. Burke
showed yesterday when it goes down to
essentially no new cases no deaths at a
period of time I think it makes sense
that you're gonna have to relax social
distancing what was that no new cases or
deaths that's what we're waiting for
couldn't that be months or years away
couldn't that potentially never happen
if it becomes endemic so what are you
saying that now he did say for a period
of time so what's that mean are we
waiting until there's no deaths or new
cases for a day well even that could be
many months out who knows and also
there's the question of what the social
distancing mean in this context it seems
clear to me that in this context it
means exactly what we're doing now in
fact you just you heard in the clip we
played earlier of dr. Falchi where he
was asked about the Surgeon General the
Surgeon General said that from his
perspective the social distancing
guidelines passed down by the federal
government amount to a national state
home order doctor Falchi said he agrees
with that interpretation
when he says social distancing could
last another many months or longer it
seems like he's saying a National State
homeowner could last that long because
that's because he equates the two
apparently but there's a lot of there's
a lot it's very unclear and there's a
lot of there's a lot of ambiguity in
this which is a problem and it's not
enough to say well they don't nobody
knows exactly so you have to cut them
some slack give them give them some
space let them figure it out no that's
not good enough when you're in the
process of tearing the our society apart
and ruining the economy no we're not
gonna cut you slack you need to be more
specific you just you need to be number
five okay how about something not that's
non Corona related you've heard of Tiger
king I'm sure the Netflix documentary
about Joe exotic the zoo owner and the
other weirdo zoo owners well it turns
out that some of the people portrayed in
that documentary do not shockingly do
not much appreciate their portrayal so
reading from a daily wire report says
according to People magazine bhagavaan
da cantle who runs a famed exotic animal
preserve in Myrtle Beach South Carolina
told TMX news that Tiger king falsely
portrayed him as a cult-like polygamist
asserting that the filmmakers misled him
on the show subject Hansol says remember
this is not a documentary this is a
salacious outrageous ride through a
television show produced to create drama
to just tie you into some crazy train
wreck of a story between the feud of
Caryl Baskin and Joe exotic and the
meltdown that ensued so he says just to
summarize he says that he thought they
were doing a documentary about his
charitable conservation work that he's
doing in Africa and and according to him
he worked with a director for over two
years he was asked hundreds of questions
in in these marathon interview sessions
only a few of the questions were about
Joe exotic and all the soap opera there
yet they the documentary maker tossed
out all of that other material that
da cantle thought the show was about and
only included the stuff about Joe exotic
I don't know if that's true or not but
it does remind us that when you're
watching and I watch this this
documentary - it is I have nothing to
say that hasn't already been said about
it it's fascinating and entertaining but
it does remind us that when you're
watching these Netflix documentaries
that are so popular now especially the
true-crime stuff it is it's
entertainment it's a show so to call it
a documentary it's like we call it that
almost as a euphemism it's really just
entertainment think about making a
murderer and how they were able to that
was I thought was a fascinating
quote-unquote documentary it was great
TV great entertainment now we could talk
about the ethical implications of
finding entertainment out of a real-life
murder that does feel a little dirty a
little bit wrong but in any case you are
you watch making murder when that came
out and it was it really made Steven
Avery seem like this seemed like this
decent good guy innocent man and then
you sit down you actually do some
research into the case afterwards and
you find out that no he was a mass
murdering well not mass murdering but
certainly a murdering rapist psychopath
that was pretty clear but they left out
a lot of details and they were able to
shape the story how they wanted it very
easily probably could have happened -
with this Joe exotic thing who knows
okay finally actually number six let me
that's what I had a bonus a bonus story
I wanted to throw in here a little bit
of good news some good news I wanted to
put in a doctor appeared on Laura
Ingraham show yesterday and said that he
thinks we're nearing the end of the
pandemic because of a medical
breakthrough that is very significant
listen to this you pointed out that not
a single patient of yours kovat patient
that has been on the hydroxi regimen has
had to be intubated for people who don't
know what intubated means please explain
quickly yeah so in a beta means your
respiratory even respiratory failure and
have to be put on a ventilator
innovation means actually putting - the
tube
and you trach in then you're placed on a
ventilator for support rest or support
we've had mentioned 20 innovations over
most all that occurred in the first two
days more importantly no person has
received five days or more of the
hydroxychloroquine zero combination has
been innovated the chance of that
occurring by chance according to my
son's Leon and Hunter who did some stats
for me are point zero zero zero or
something it's ridiculous to look at it
yeah it's ridiculously loaded about how
you look at Laura I think this is the
beginning of the end of the pandemic I'm
very serious
Wow this is unbelievable a little light
at the end of the on the end of the
tunnel there maybe perhaps let's move on
to your daily cancellation today we're
canceling snitches all the snitches
America has turned into a nation of
snitches many local news outlets around
the country have articles like this one
in wusa9 s website pertaining to the DC
Maryland Virginia area the headline is
who to call if you spot someone not
complying with the stay at home orders
in the DMV DC Maryland Virginia and then
it continues prior to the new state home
orders announced across the DMV today
Maryland State Police tweeted that
they've already received 378 calls
reporting businesses or individuals not
in compliance with the governor's
previous executive order they also
confirmed two arrests have been made one
in Charles County and another in Carroll
County and then it says I think it goes
on and it says that among the people
reported by their neighbors and arrested
was a man who had a barbecue and then it
gives the potential penalties it says in
DC if you're convicted of defying these
orders you could face 90 days in prison
of $5,000 fine in Maryland one year in
prison and a $5000 fine in that Virginia
one year in prison and a $2,500 fine
also an article in the AP residents
snitch on businesses neighbors amid
shutdowns and gives some examples in nag
nag Atuk Connecticut resident Gwen
Becker said she was mortified when she
drove by a golf course and saw a crowd
gathered around a food truck and eating
at tables together so she took a video
that her friend posted on
Facebook prompting the mayor to shut
down the course and then other other
examples of that and some some states
have made snitching pretty easy this is
a form I want to show you this
apparently a form is a screen shot
somebody sent to me and looks like it's
been taken down since then maybe because
of the public outcry but here's
something from the Idaho State
government a stay at home compliance
form and you could see how they made it
really easy to just put in the name of
the business you want to snitch on and
it's a very easy very easy process
there's a bunch of other videos I don't
even play them but a bunch of other
videos of people being confronted for
not following the state home orders and
neighbors threatening to call the cops
and everything else listen I know people
are scared I know they think they're
doing the right thing and being a hero
by calling the cops but I can tell you
this there is no disease there is no
pandemic that would ever turn me into
the kind of person who calls the cops on
my neighbors for having a barbecue I
don't care if it's an actual apocalypse
I there are some things that are not
worth it to become the sort of Americans
turning your fellow citizens into the
authorities for being outside I'm sorry
that is it's it's not worth whatever few
ounces of safety you think you've
purchased for yourself in fact I was at
a park few days ago and I saw a few
people playing basketball which probably
they're not supposed to be doing
am I gonna report that to the police
hell no you know what I do out of mind
my own business they're not hurting me
and for all I know they could be family
members and what's the big deal it
they're gonna be together in their house
or at a basketball court who cares
what's the difference really I'm simply
not going to be the kind of person who
calls the police and says yeah there was
three people peacefully playing
basketball at a you know a public public
hoop many many feet away from the
nearest other person that's not worth it
giving up your dignity not worth it give
your liberty completely and embracing of
an authoritarian state as we have done
is not worth it
giving up the entire economy and
embracing an economic crash that
destroys millions of lives that's not
worth it lots of things are worth it to
stem the spread of a dangerous disease
there are lots of measures that are
worth it but these are just some things
that are not worth it and that's
regardless of the threat we're getting
to this place now where it's believed
basically that it's okay to do anything
anything at all to stop people from
dying from this disease from this
disease we'll do anything at all to stop
people from dying from this from this
particular thing but in saner times when
everybody isn't scared we realize that
the whole point of not being a coward
the whole point of being an American who
values higher things than safety is that
you don't treat death as the ultimate
absolute worst thing that must be
avoided at any and all costs it's a bad
thing that we tried to avoid but not at
any and all costs there are costs that
are too high to pay from the arguments
people are making now it seems like
they're saying there is no cost too high
to pay we will do anything at all but
again in more rational times when we're
past all of this whenever that happens
people are gonna look back and I don't
think everyone's gonna be very proud of
the way that they acted and those
Americans who are peering out their
window calling up the cops niching on
their neighbors because they see them
outside for an unapproved reason are
they gonna feel proud of it I know right
now they feel like it okay because
they're scared
so all the snitches are canceled
altogether
finally let's go to some emails let's
see here
this is from Michael says hello Matt
serious question do you think this is
the end of the United States and will
Americans have to utilize the Second
Amendment this year I am sure millions
if not tens of millions people have that
in the back of their mind
thanks love the show what do you mean
the end of the United States I certainly
think something called the United States
will continue to exist after this and in
many ways it will probably look a lot
like it does now but I do think that in
the midst of this unprecedented
government power grab and the surrender
of a scared populace that we are losing
things that we'll probably never get
back and that America is being reshaped
as we speak into a more authoritarian
state into a place where small
businesses are increasingly going
extinct a small handful of corporations
are taking over yes I think that that's
what we're looking at and you might say
as I said you might say that we were on
the way to that already which is
probably true but we're gonna get there
a lot sooner
now I believe let's see is there
anything else here this is from no name
given but it says it's easy to complain
Matt but what is your solution really
would you actually let churches gather
right now do you think that's the right
course do you actually think churches
should be getting together with mass
groups of people in a pandemic it was
just the same point I've responded to a
million times as far as my actual yes I
have given what I consider to be my not
maybe not a salute I don't know I don't
have a solution nobody has a solution
nobody has a switch you can flip and
make everything better that doesn't
exist so I don't have that but I do have
I have proposed many I'm not gonna
repeat myself I've said it so many times
what I think what what we could do
instead rather than destroying the
economy there are other things we could
do while also taking into account the
pandemic and taking it very seriously
and trying as much as we can to stop the
spread without destroying the economy
there are steps we could take I've
suggested some of those steps so you
just go back and read what I've written
or listen to other shows and you can
find it do I think the churches should
gather right now
many churches probably should not
especially if you're in a place like New
York or being big urban area you
probably shouldn't be but not every
place is New York I think there are
places in America that are not nearly as
hard-hit where there are very few
confirmed cases and of course there
could be cases that are not confirmed
probably our you know there's gonna be a
greater percentage of cases that are not
confirmed but there are places in
America that are relatively remote that
are further away setback and and don't
have the same level of of a problem and
do I think that they'd be okay to meet
for church probably as long as you're
taking precautions and you're being
smart about it
I'm not telling people that they should
go run out and have a church it's not
for me to decide but that's beside the
point but what I'm saying whether or not
it that's a good idea I think that's
situational it depends on the situation
that you're in
depends on where you live what the
situation is I think we have to stop
looking for a one-size-fits-all approach
the idea that the problem is exactly the
same everywhere in the country and so
that we should treat it the same
everywhere in the country is crazy
it doesn't make any sense
but regardless it's not about what I
think churches should do what I'm saying
is we should not be a country where the
government shuts churches by force and
arrests pastors for holding church
services even if what the past even if
the pastor is is in a situation even if
the church is somewhere where probably
they shouldn't be meeting then we can
ask them not to me we can apply social
pressure we can encourage people right
just like there were so many churches
before all of this before the government
started forcing the issue there were
many churches hundreds probably most
across the country that had already
chosen to stop services for the time
being on their own they made that
decision fine great free decision by
free people
but I simply don't think we become we
can become we have become this kind of
country but we should not have become
the kind of country where we shut
churches by force and arrest pastors
period I don't think that could ever be
worth it I don't think that's something
we should ever do in this country and
like I said there will come a time the
not so distant future when everybody
will pretend to agree with that
sentiment when people will start saying
things like you know give me liberty
give me death you don't want to trade
Liberty for safety those sorts of
slogans everybody loves those slogans
loves the idea
loves the sentiment until the rubber
meets the road or that you know what
hits the fan so I guess we have to
decide those slogans those things that
we pretend to live by as Americans do
they really mean anything at all or are
we just is that just a lie we tell
ourselves I think that's what we have to
try to figure that out we'll leave it
there thank somebody for watching thanks
for listening stay safe out there god
bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 rents are due but no one is
working and that's just one of the
practical challenges that comes with
shutting down the global economy
fortunately socialist congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez has the
solution if you can figure out what
she's saying then speaking of not
speaking well Joe Biden proposes
postponing the DNC despite widespread
fears that time is not exactly on Joe's
side we will examine what the move would
mean for the Democratic Party all that
and more check it out on the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]